good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday it is
finally stopped raining here in new york
the skies are clear or so are our minds
from our fabulous relaxing hopeful
hopefully relaxing everyone had a
relaxing weekend good morning brother
good morning
oh my god that was our last episode my
god what how
what positive feedback we got i know you
guys that was so much fun but i
literally needed the whole weekend to
decompress
because i left it all on this couch you
left
everything on the couch we'd have a
cleaning crew come in and clean up all
the things that you left
like once a year i gave it all i give
every
comedic instinct i have today so i leave
it all on this couch
and i need the rest of the year to
recoup and recharge for next
halloween right but it was so amazing i
that was
hands down my favorite one we've ever
done same i mean we
what i loved about it is that nobody
guessed it so many people thought we
were gonna be david and alexis okay
let's talk about
our plans initially and what we were
saying and what i wanted to be versus
what you had to be
because i thought that i had had the
idea like three months ago and like we
we didn't need to but you didn't like it
i wanted to be viola and sebastian
hastings and i just thought
like while i love she's the man you know
how i feel about that film
i thought it was a confusing costume one
because
if one of us is sebastian like as he is
like that person
no because i know we're both going to be
amanda yeah amanda mine says viola and
amanda binds to sebastian but like
that's one
that's two people playing one person
it's just a little confusing i think
you're looking too much into it and i
think it would have been absolutely
stellar but i'll keep it in my back
pocket if i have you know maybe i'll do
it with bed next year
i would love to see that it's it's a
premier idea and i won't let you [ __ ] on
it i wanted to be
david and alexis rose from shit's creek
which would have been great and i think
a lot of people guessed it i would have
been david and you would have been
alexis
yeah you weren't excited about playing
alexis and it requires
everyone having watched its creek which
like even though it feels like it not
everyone does
no also why i didn't like it well one
it's so much more fun to be david than
it is to be alexis and like it's never
good when one is better than the other i
mean i would have been alexis i just
think that would have been more expected
yeah and it's also like kind of she's
like lame like she's great but she
doesn't except for david like there's
not a lot
and literally everyone in the world did
some like shit's creek variation so i'm
glad we were like unique yeah i mean i
did wind up being shitscreen on saturday
night zach and i were
moira and johnny rose and once i knew
that i was going to do that with zach i
didn't really care
about doing it here for the show by the
way you
did shit's creek probably better than
i've seen anyone do it wow
and it's so much better to dress up as
moira and johnny than it is to dress up
as david and alex he's like if you
wanted to do moira and johnny like i
would have put on the eyebrows like
yeah no brainer but we do siblings we
try to do siblings
every year it'll probably be different
we always want to be family members but
it's so much fun more siblings and the
royal family was just like
it was perfect i had so much fun i mean
crazy harry like he's [ __ ] nuts i'll
never look at him the same again
i took i had to get my work back out
this morning and i opened it i'm like
why does it feel like a little bulkier
like my
wig was in there and i was just like
harking back
oh i don't know if this made the um fast
five i don't believe that it did but i
think we should talk about the fact that
i had coronavirus as of april this year
oh yeah and i was
having a very hard time breathing
brother william prince william had
coveted in april not claudia ashrae just
want to set that up for yeah but not
julia with a british accent no and
claudia ashrae with a british accent
still has not had coveted
no neither has uh even i have nearly a
time been
uh charged with being a coven denier by
some of my haters or a coveted spreader
and like you can super spreader can't
spread covet if you don't get coven and
at this point i feel like now i'm
actually like in the worst position ever
i'm like the most vulnerable member of
society right because
i haven't had it i mean most people i
know like have had it either super bad
or they didn't even know and then they
have antibodies like i'm never gonna be
that person
but um as i feel like we're heading
towards another lockdown like i still
have not gotten it
no i i mean same i mean because if you
had it then i would have it right
and vice versa and it's like weird to be
annoyed at about it but like i kind of
wish
like i had gone through it already right
yeah that would be like more immune
right i think a lot of people feel that
way so it was a great halloweekend
yes it was hope everyone had a fun time
and they dressed up as well a little amy
poehler action
well i wasn't planning on dressing up
because i really like i give it
all to the toast and because we do it
all on the toast i don't feel
pressured to dress up after the fact
like i love the fact that
we are always celebrating halloween on
the toast and i don't have to go get
like a [ __ ] costume
for a party on saturday night yeah and i
didn't have like a party to go to i was
just hanging out with like
five friends but i literally happen to
have
in my bag this juicy track suit and i
was like what can i do with this
so i found a wig it wasn't the right wig
but i went as amy poehler from mean
girls and actually ended up being
hilarious you know when you wear a wig
some i mean you know from harry
some wigs have like supernatural um
powers that like
seep from your hair follicles into your
brain cells and transform you into like
a
truly different person and you have this
alter ego this amy polar wig like
even though it was more like an anna
nicole smith wig it made me nuts
yeah no i am very aware of the power of
wigs and i feel like that is something
that
moyra rose is always saying like each
wig those are her girls like
they're different people and i so i
think that i
actually love the feeling of halloween
when
you just get this new persona and i feel
like in regular time a lot of times like
people go all out for halloween you know
hard on makeup hard on outfit and like
everyone's just really feels themselves
and then everyone said that halloween's
over because like you're you don't get
to be that person anymore but it's like
be that person more often of course take
on new personalities take on new
personalities go balls to the walls do
full glam like it's really fun
and i feel like actually every halloween
when i have to do like my makeup as
someone else
i learned something new about makeup and
i actually for the first time i did like
black eyeshadow to be moira
and i kind of liked how it looked when i
took my wig off later and like i feel
like now i'll be experimenting with
darker eye shadows
thanks to the power of mario rose that's
she's she's so powerful
yeah um also i feel like there's really
two types of girls on halloween like
girls who just like wear so much makeup
feathers like with no real like
costumes costume it's just like sexy
angel
like it's just like arbitrary like
sexiness where it's like or you go like
balls to the wall like you put on a bald
cap and like you don't care
if you look sexy you just like want to
nail the costume and that's okay
and i think what a halloween costume
means in 2020 and like last year too
is really transforming because now like
it's so much about getting the picture
that looks like a picture that you're
resembling and then you just like post
the two photos or like doing a tick tock
like impersonation so like now it's not
enough just to have a costume and go to
a party like
you have to like create a short feature
film like a
a stylized photo in the same vein of
your characters like what they're saying
on the social dilemma like but i think
that that is actually like
ultimately a good thing like where
everyone's being more creative like your
creative juices are flowing
yeah i saw like a lot of cool content on
my feed and it was actually great for
covid times so i think a lot of people
did dress up to take pictures and sit in
their house i mean that's what i did
yeah
and i had a great time doing it of
course it's actually better yeah so it
was good for this year but in general i
just think it's a cool thing that
people are doing um so yes also on
friday night i dressed up as an author
oh yeah it was really cool you didn't
have to wear anything did you
no i didn't because i am an author my
book comes out january 26
2021 if you'd like to pre-order it uh as
an e-book a regular hardcover book at
audiobook girlwithnojob.combook
or you can just go to my instagram girl
with no job and check it out all the
pre-order links are now available so now
if you want to pre-order my audiobook on
audible or on google play
it is available also if you want to
support local bookstores which i feel
like in these unprecedented
times we should all be supporting local
bookstores my book is available at tons
of indie book stores and you can check
it all out at girlfriendjob.com
book book um so yes hope everyone had a
happy halloween
yeah it was a very i had a great weekend
because it was my first weekend home
with my little man bruno
and he is just like the most special
thing in the world and
actually daylight savings um thank you
to the farmers it worked perfectly for
me this year
because i ignored the extra hour
yesterday and i took it this morning
and now i have to get up an hour earlier
to do all the things i need to do and
make sure
it is all good to go so i just
incorporated it into this morning
and i think actually i'm this might this
growing pain of having to get up earlier
just i might have just avoided it
completely with daylight savings
well at first i was like so lit up about
daylight savings like an extra hour and
i woke up at 9 45 which was really 10 45
i felt so well rested
and then by last night like it was i was
waiting for a real house as a potomac to
start and i could not keep my eyes open
like
i felt so dramatic you know when people
like go to dallas and they're like an
hour time
and they're like i'm so jealous like
relax you to go to europe
but like that was me last night like the
one hour just [ __ ] killed me
yeah it was it was a trippy sort of day
and it was raining and you know what's
so interesting ever since i've gotten
bruno it has rained every single day
and it reminds me of that bruno mars
song every day will rain
rain rain
by the way that is that bruno's namesake
yes brood of ours
yeah that makes a lot of sense oh that
is oh by the way for a lot of reasons we
named him bruno but one of the biggest
ones is that zach and i's favorite
artist is bruno mars
he's a classic talent
[Music]
yeah can't god just stay here
spend the rest of my days here
bruno mars is like truly like a
world-renowned talent
yeah and it's been three million years
since he got released new music and i
like i just think it's time
no i think it's time to and and because
it's been so long that makes me feel
like it's coming
yeah i also feel like he went so hard
like balls to the wall on the most
recent album like won all the grammys
went on two tours i saw him twice at
barclays center like a year apart
like he went so hard like he needs a
break yeah and normalized taking breaks
and i think that he is taking that break
yeah so i'm happy for him i'm happy for
my little bruno like yesterday was
raining and he and i took a nap
in bed together and it was just
beautiful heavenly
and it makes picking up all that poop
just so much work like nothing yeah it's
like nothing it's nothing
water off a duck's back exactly duty off
of bruno's
butthole um we have a great show for you
guys today of course we have the past
five stories i had like some more
anecdotes i wanted to show oh i'm so
sorry
because i watched a lot of stuff well
that's what i was just about to say is
in our tv recap segment we will of
course be recapping because it's monday
real housewives of potomac but jackie
and i both finished the queen's gamut on
netflix and
i just need to discuss and i watch yes
need to discuss
i watched american murder family next
door yeah have you watched
chris watts you guys just survived
so disturbing and i also watched the
holiday with emma roberts oh okay i've
been curious um
to hear p it's like it has a lot of
steam like people are talking about it i
haven't seen any of the steam and
i i won't recap it because you'll watch
it but i just want to say it was
so good and cute and she is just so
funny yeah and i i love her and i
probably laughed out loud three or four
times
and that is the mark of a good movie it
was really cute i mean it's not going to
change your life or anything
but if you're just looking it's really
long so i don't know if you can handle
it
like i thought i was in the middle and
then i still had an hour left oh yeah
it's like an hour 40.
so but i just
i feel like every even if the script
wasn't good i wouldn't have known
because everything she does like she's
just like stellar
stellar yeah i agree and i thought it
was really cute so
love love if you were on the fence
definitely go for it you know actually
you know
because it's now november first we're
officially in holiday season but it's
also not just a christmas movie
it's a year round well i was really like
almost feeling compelled
to turn on the hallmark channel last
night because and actually
like the you could tell like the air is
different especially here in new york
like it's
definitely holiday season and i actually
have been like really feeling like i
want to move apartments just because
like i want to have like a holiday
like my i don't know my my apartment is
not giving me holiday vibes do you know
what that means
yeah i mean there's a few things easy
things you could do to give it the
holiday vibe
candles yeah i mean i guess it's like
dramatic to like move for a holiday
like why don't you at least attempt to
get the holiday vibe like
i think i need a christmas tree and i
know we like always talk about how jews
who have christmas trees or such frauds
um and i stand by that statement but
like i really understand those people
because like i really want to be one
yeah no i think you can have everything
but a christmas tree it's just like
where's the only one i want what about a
reef
is that like so like not jewish
not jewish yeah because what a candle
what else um
like you could have scented candles like
whichever christmas scents you love the
most
maybe a little mistletoe um
garland garlic but i don't have a mantle
or anything
put up lights fairy lights love that
yeah
it's just like a little and hanukkah is
the festival of lights i would i would
go with the lights
maybe i'll go like hard to the like with
the with the hanukkah
designs a little guilt yeah i forgot
dreidel dreidel i made you out of tips
all right well it's just like it's that
seasonal depression for jewish people
like it's coming up you know
that's why we have to go hard with what
we do have and that's what i always
strive to do
yeah that's a really good attitude i
just feel like in these unprecedented
times like i'm so unmotivated to do like
anything like my work my hobbies like i
can barely watch tv i'm just
so unmotivated so when it comes to like
holiday decor i'm just like real it's
like so low on my list
i think if you prioritized it it would
pay off in droves
maybe you can't i'll get to i have a lot
of candles in my house i'm gonna bring
you some tomorrow
okay are you coming over tomorrow no
i'll bring them here oh okay fabulous
because i have a lot of like spare
candles and i could spare a candle to a
friend
yeah i also think like i have truly been
hibernating in my bedroom specifically
you gotta switch it up move to the
living room i think i need to start
investing in my living room like it's so
unhealthy to literally get into bed at
when we get home from the toast it's
like one o'clock and literally like not
leave till the next morning like and
don't get me wrong i'm so productive i
literally wrote my whole book from my
bed but like
i i think like my mental health is like
so severely declining like i think i
need to move into living room wow you
know what's crazy it literally took you
like nine months of quarantine to get to
this
state you know my threshold is really
high your threshold is really high
because i remember when we did the
all steams on decks zoom and we were
like who's suffering the most and
everyone's like jackie
yeah like i had no idea but you would be
you would have been like the last one
yeah so to hear you get to this point
like that's really sad
and i do think it has to do with the
weather yes and the fact that like there
is another lockdown like
looming don't say it so every time i say
like how long we've been in quarantine i
was just like i'm like it's been 12
years it's been
30 years no totally like i keep like
exaggerating
no like now that it's november 1st it's
nine months i don't know if that's true
but that's it how it goes in my head my
living room also still has a fire stick
because i never sit in there and i don't
give a [ __ ] about it
so i just don't really i can't hang out
there until i get another apple tv it's
like so toxic with the fire stick oh so
toxic and like the delayed remote it's
just like
it's living in another century like my
bedroom is a 21st century xenon
and my living room is like truly
colonial times
damn well that's another thing you could
do to
turn your presence maybe i should like
redecorate okay like because we've all
been living in our houses for so long
and everyone on tick tock is doing like
diy
like new furniture and i think that like
i need to
redecorate i think that would be like
fun yeah i mean i'm moving which is why
i'm not in the same boat as you
otherwise i would be like what can i do
i'm going to paint my walls but since
i'm moving soon i
i'm looking forward to like a literal
change of scenery see i think that's
i'm just going to say you want to move
and olivia just moved you're
moving like i'm jealous of like everyone
moving and like i'm still staying in my
bed
yeah but you also have a great apartment
and i love my apartment i think if i
moved like it would be so hasty it would
be the extremely hasty move
and i would regret it yeah i think you
would come to regret it as well okay so
i'll just like i'll spruce it up
yeah i think we could do some really fun
stuff you guys like spam her with like
stuff and i'm thinking maybe like of a a
wallpaper moment
a lot of crazy no i think that's so
exciting what kind of what
kind of like this but like also i love
the whole vibe of like
one wall having wallpaper and like the
rest being white you do it
okay i love that okay jackie approves
i think that's so exciting you know who
else would enjoy that the little man
i mean he's the big man now because i
have a little man at home and now seeing
him come in here he's like a lion
he's a labrador like a huge [ __ ]
golden retriever 100
um so now do you think so now i do think
it's time now that i got that all off my
chest
um it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and i'm thrilled humbled and honored
t-h-h thrilled humbled and honored to
let everyone know that today's episode
is brought to you by
probably i'm going to say it my favorite
sponsor thera breath
oh it's winning i mean we literally keep
a pack of their gum right behind our
little flower pot if you're watching on
youtube
because it is like a their whole mission
is to just help get rid of bad breath
and as someone who not only suffers from
toxic breath but also has a very special
nose and can smell it on other people
before other people can smell it
um it's really interesting that i have
these powers i'm so
like living for the power of their
breath the world's fastest growing oral
health care solution because it really
works
their products aren't just effective
they're clean and ethical too all of
their products so they make mouthwash
mince gum i've been using all of them i
bring them all home i mean we have a ton
at the studio but i brought them all
home because ben also suffers from the
breath
um they're all kosher vegan and
gluten-free and we keep a kosher
household which is fabulous
um none of their oral risk rinses are
tested on animals so theo approves and
they're all made in the usa with the
most ethically sourced ingredients
all thera breath products are alcohol
free so the mouthwash is no burn
and none of the products contain
artificial flavors or colors
so they have the fresh they are able to
help fresh breath they're able to help
bleeding gums and gingivitis
they help anti-activity and teeth
training and improvement
and they help dry mouth which i also am
a sufferer of dry mouth and there's
truly nothing worse than like licking
your lips 400 times a day
um and thereby just helps with it all
they're sold everywhere at target
walmart
walgreens cvs rite aid so wherever
you're listening from you should be able
to get some thera breath and you can
find their products on amazon
where they have close to 40 000 reviews
and a majority of them are five star
ratings can't relate
their breath is a social media giant and
they've been dubbed the tick tock
mouthwash because they've gone viral
multiple times and generated over 30
million views on their tagged videos
so if you're looking to um just take
care of your breath or maybe your
partner's breath it's holiday season
maybe
subtly give the gift of their breath be
sure to send
someone with bad breath or yourself over
to therabreath.com
toast that's dot com slash
t-h-e-r-a-breath.com
and if you want 25 off on your order
from the website you can use code
a toast at ost at therabreath.com
toast thera breath is like therapy for
your breath
love it sign on get better breath please
for the sake of it to the ones around
you
yeah and for yourself like yeah breath
makes me sick sometimes me too obnoxious
first story halloween 2020 the best
celeb costumes let's go through the
biggest and the best i and then we'll
talk about our favorites i mean
my winner was the weeknd as the nutty
professor just
absolutely brilliant amazing also kelsey
ballerini as a cat karen ballerini
i guess she made a video that was like
so cute and funny with like real comedic
chops yes
one of my favorites like really made me
laugh but we have kylie as
um a king cobra snake it's like a full
mugler outfit
yeah see kylie's one of the girls who
just like goes for like an arbitrary
costume like looking the most sexy as
she can and i thought she looked great
but my favorites are always going to be
something like a little bit more like
pop culture oriented topical
topical or just like more specific than
like a snake
yeah she was also the power rangers with
her group of friends cute
very cute do you still think she's
pregnant yes oh wow okay
and i'm honestly more convinced than
ever because people keep sending me like
she did the james charles video they're
like she's drinking and it's like
how do you know that first of all and
people on social media are always like
pretending not to be pregnant like
drinking alcohol to like trick everyone
so i'm just i'm more convinced than ever
just just know i haven't let up on my
conspiracy theory oh wow okay cool
haley bieber dressed as uh nurse ratch
you've seen the show oh ratched ratchet
yeah she did a great job
yeah no but it's like not that popular
of a show right i agree that'd be like
dressing up
as um beth harmon like right now yeah
it's just like it's a little
too niche it's a little too soon kim
kardashian dressed as carol baskin
and food god was joe exotic and the
babies were tigers and i'm not gonna lie
like i thought it was a little
disappointing of course of course by the
way they did it very well a lot of
people did it
tana mojo and jake paul also did it
honestly they did a good job too
and i forgot to say when people were
guessing our costumes like everyone
thought we were gonna be joe exotic and
carol baskin and honestly
that not to be like mean but that idea
lacks so much originality and creativity
the most
basic costume idea of 2020. like there's
nothing wrong with it but it's like what
i think
everyone would think of first right it's
just too basic and two would like easy
too many people guessed it it's like for
kim who goes all out every year like
when she was selena and then sunny and
cher
legally blonde yeah i was just like
really like this is it
okay like it was just like um kendall
dressed as like pamela anderson
from like an iconic photo shoot which i
wasn't familiar with but i thought the
look was amazing the brows
the brows she went all out with the
brows i thought she looked
great i mean she is not having a good
week weekend
because she is under some fire from
people on social media for throwing up
she had a is it her birthday yeah it's
her birthday birthday halloween party
like about 100 people
um and like the uh i guess they had
passed around flyers at the party saying
like
please don't post on social media like
take all the pictures you want but don't
post
and like the party was posted everywhere
because it was like star started the
weekend was there justin bieber was
there all of her sisters were there
kylie was the one like posting the most
and like kendall was posing for all
these pictures so it was like confusing
like did you want people not to be on
social media or did you
yeah jayden smith was also there and
he's um
getting a lot of [ __ ] because people
think he dressed as a coped patient but
it turned out i read somewhere that he
was dressed as
uh someone's character from this new
movie tenant
tenant oh i don't know i don't know um
also sweetie was there she looked
amazing oh my god
she [ __ ] killed did you see also
sweetie two nights ago
dressed up as rupaul just for a photo
shoot yes yes oh my god she looked
amazing
amazing also um christine quinn dressed
as christina aguilera
that's always an amazing costume when
it's done well during the dirty era
and i thought she hid it out of the park
christine aguilera herself dressed as an
alien cute arbitrary yeah arbitrary
christian siriano dressed as sia
really really good i love when
celebrities dress as other celebrities
like sierra
dressed as cardi b um and she recreated
like her iconic uh album cover and she
dresses two other artists who i can't
remember right now like lil naj dressed
as um
so good so good see a lot a lot of
celebrities pretty much just like
dressed up and did photo shoots and like
didn't go anywhere that's what like lil
nas did and that's what sierra did or if
they went somewhere like we're just not
privy to it
right right right um and then also
or they like took their kids trick or
treating or whatever speaking of
gabrielle union and dwayne ray
wade were um s'mores so cute so cute
and gabrielle union um did like a whole
collage on her instagram i have to say
following gabrielle union on instagram
it's like
i can't recommend it enough it's just
it's so
like her content is so diverse like it's
bring it on and it's it's just like a
million things and she did a collage
like
all the girls who dressed up as bringing
on like how much it means to her like
this movie still means so much to people
and she dressed up as the clovers last
year um and it's just it's the best like
the fact that she embraces like her
clover's
um role so proudly is like the best
thing ever
wow that's really sweet um so those were
some of my highlights anyone else that
you saw that you wanted to share who do
you think was
best dressed uh j.lo and a-rod dressed
as madonna and
i think that's who that is it was okay i
mean
like i said for me i go for like the
the concept more than like the sexiness
yeah no the concept plus the execution
yeah so really honestly like the weekend
one halloween for me yeah
i agree he was a nutty professor and i
we used to
love those movies and he looked just
like eddie murphy
and it was such a unique idea like i
don't think i've ever seen anyone do
that and i love a pop culture moment so
all of those things wrapped up
i think he was my winner what about you
i i i'm gonna agree with you execution
plus idea a plus
yeah and he looked great like the
pictures were good and then he was like
walking around
like his party like dressed as the nutty
professor it was hilarious
really good stuff i'm glad everyone had
fun with it
and had a had a good safe time happy
halloween everyone
yes um it's just like such a bummer
halloween was honest that was like the
meme of 2020 like
halloween's gonna be on saturday night
like all the other holidays are like on
the perfect days
and like we couldn't even celebrate yeah
well i feel like everyone made
the most may do of their situations
because to be honest like staying at
home with a few friends like
that is not my idea of a bad time like
that's fabulous me neither like and for
me like getting dressed up and then
taking like some cute pictures and
content and then like
the shapiro's came over like such an
iconic happy halloween to me
and i i feel like the people who like
really like missed out the most are like
kids in college because like that's so
fun when you're in college
um so like that sucks for them yeah okay
next story speaking of our halloween
costumes this is actually really crazy
not confirmed but the royal biographer
says that queen elizabeth will pass the
throne to charles next year
the eldest son of queen elizabeth would
ascend to the throne in just six months
if his mother steps down on her next
birthday as the royal biographer
predicts
he said i still firmly believe that when
the queen becomes 95 that she will step
down
elizabeth marks another year on april
21st she was all of 27 when she was
crowned in 1952
on the death of her father charles
turned 72
in two weeks first of all like what a
legacy
like for queen elizabeth she was queen
when she was 25 training
how old is she now 94. wow and do most
monarchs
give up the throne or just die die got
it and she would
intentionally give it up yeah she would
like this is what he's predicting
this is what he's predicting and he's
the royal biographer so i guess
his prediction holds some weight yeah i
mean it's just also crazy to me that
prince charles would become king when
he's 72. it's like you're so
old like what's the point um and i
totally am like a supporter of them just
like skipping him because he seems like
such a loser but i guess that's not how
it works over in london
um but i don't know something about this
like
the queen she has done her duty like she
is more than entitled to like resigning
and like retiring and enjoying the rest
of her life
but she's so good at it like i feel like
we should get as many years of qe as we
can
i agree and so i'm gonna go on the
record and say
i don't think this is gonna happen me
neither i think she
will serve out her reign
she's an amazing monarch she's an
institution
why just because she turns a certain
number does that mean that her like
that she should or shouldn't be the
queen yeah and also i feel
like what i gather from the crown is
that like
her priority is always like protecting
the crown protecting the monarchy
and i think she knows that like the best
way to do that is to
if charles is going to be king like give
him the least amount of time that he
possibly can
and as long as she's queen like the
crown is safe and like she's the best at
it it's like she knows like
locations to keep herself in the in the
throne for as long as possible
yeah i totally agree i'm i'm i mean i
hope this isn't true and i wanna
i'm gonna put it out there that i don't
think this is to happen especially maybe
maybe that was going to happen at one
point in time but like with this year
like she just lost out on a year of
do being queenie like she needs another
year and
and the royal family has had so much
like tabloid drama
in the last year two years that i feel
like she's looking for some stability
and that's not going to come from
charles i'm sorry
and another shake-up isn't what they
need right now they have a few good
quiet years i agree and i think the way
we do that is by
qe just staying on and then
william me did you see gary gennetti
posted
his show prince george had like
he posted princess charlotte is sophie
turner by sophie turner yes i haven't
seen
did the show come out yet no i don't
think so okay because i'm so looking
forward to it
and i pay for hbo max but i haven't seen
it yet i love the casting being
sophie turner for charlotte it's so good
so good
excellent five stars to whoever idea
that was yeah
agreed and gary is the voice of george
yes got it okay very exciting to keep
tabs on when that's coming out speaking
of keeping tabs the crown comes out
november 15th exciting the day after
charles's birthday happy birthday that's
so soon it's already november oh
chilling chilling my birthday's this
week wow i haven't mentioned it oh yeah
you haven't
i know i even did this little birthday
manicure for myself
um so that's exciting can you believe
that like
you turning i'm i'm turning 21. i'm
excited to have my first sip of alcohol
um can you believe that my birthday's in
november and it's still gonna be like
a quarantine birthday no i know and we
were like literally thinking like okay
ben's was in april
probably be quarantined but mine in july
would never be and like here we are
here we are so that's exciting yeah
so you're going to tell us how old
you're turning into sure i mean i'm not
ashamed of my age i'm going to be 28.
oh i thought you're gonna be 29 that's
fine okay i think you're totally fine
okay thanks next story some little young
love
news noah centennial and stars stassi
baby
hold hands while celebrating halloween
together there have been rumors about
them for a while there were rumors that
they got married and like eloped in
vegas and then i never heard any
follow-up to that
yeah but they're confirming that they
are together
they stepped out stressed as chucky
held his hand as they walked into a
party together he appeared to be dressed
up as one of her victims with a bloody
slash across his t-shirt
oh that's very original like so like
it's so
i saw a tick tock about this because i
re-downloaded a tic toc to make my moyer
video
and it's like the amount of effort and
like
glamour that women put into their
halloween costumes it's like the men you
are unworthy she's like showing up in a
jersey
yeah it ain't right it ain't right but
these two are
together and it's cute i'm here for it
well so i don't even remember formally
dealing with his breakup with alexis ren
i feel like maybe that just like fizzled
out yeah we didn't formally deal with it
at all there was no formal statement or
like formality formal
formalness if there was it wasn't formal
enough for like us to report to formally
report on it yeah in a formal sort of
way
right and that formality is so necessary
during these unprecedented times but it
seems as though these two are formally
announcing that yeah together that's
cute no i actually think this is a good
like young hollywood couple
yeah i think it's and like noah
centennial like
being on you know in in in a close group
of friends with kylie like that works
for me yeah and like it's like
reality tv young hollywood and like
wyatt
movies young hollywood like we're all
hanging out how do you pronounce his
last name
noah centennial even though i know it's
sentinel centennial but like i think
like i like noah centennial me too it
works for me that's how i like grew up
learned like
i grew up like the last two years but
like that's how i believed it was and
that's how it shall be
yeah no i feel you so happy for these
cuties
yeah that's a cute couple i actually
really like that like very good looking
very good looking
well speaking of um half of a cute
couple megan fox claims x brian austin
green is so intoxicated
with portraying her as an absent mother
this is
shook worthy megan fox took to the
comments section of her ex brian austin
green's halloween social media post to
call him out about publicly sharing
pictures of their child
she said she took notice of his post
that featured their youngest son
she said why does journey have to be in
this picture it's not hard to crop them
out or choose photos that they aren't
in i had a great halloween with them
yesterday and yet notice how absent they
are from my social media i know you love
your kids but i don't know why you can't
stop using them
to posture via instagram you're so
intoxicated with feeding the pervasive
narrative that i'm an absent mother
and you are the perennial eternally
dedicated dad of the year you have them
half the time
congratulations you are truly a
remarkable human why do you need the
internet to echo back to you
what should be inexhaustibly evident in
the way your children love you
okay i just have to say i'm so team
megan fox here
because first of all people um all over
social media especially with megan fox
and
machine gun kelly's relationship are
like where are your kids it's like she
takes one picture with her boyfriend
everyone's like
oh you're never with your kids and it's
like this narrative that's just been
created about her and i'm sure he's
aware of it and i know she's aware of it
because it
has to be hurtful for people to just be
like saying [ __ ] like that even though
they have no clue
what actually goes on in her life and
yes in a lot of ways like
he definitely feeds into it and there's
so much we don't know and he definitely
and
if they have 50 50 custody like she's
hanging out with her boyfriend like
okay the kids are with him like it's not
a big deal yeah just because you posted
something on social media like doesn't
mean jack [ __ ]
yeah no it's so frustrating and it must
be really frustrating for her and so i
know a lot of people were like
is this the place to air your dirty
laundry but it's like this is a part of
being a celebrity and i'm sure megan fox
over the last couple months has gotten
like
so many like dms and comments and like
just
negativity about the fact that like it
appears like she's not with her children
when it's like
[ __ ] off they have a dad first of all
second of all leave her alone like she's
a mom she knows what she's doing [ __ ]
off
yeah and instead of posting in his
comments what you want her
what she could have done is like taken
to her instagram and posted pictures of
the kids like why would she use kids as
pawns
right in this situation and just instead
like just publicly say to him
we know what you're doing we know what
you're doing i don't know i kind of
lived for this i'm not gonna lie
i didn't i didn't never really thought
that about this like
because i don't follow either of them so
like it's not on my radar but
i have mad respect for her doing this
and i loved what she said
and i think that actually you know what
hater's gonna [ __ ] hate yeah
i was watching this documentary american
murder and it's like
the craziest saddest most tragic
senseless
story and somehow on social media like
this woman and her
two girls were murdered by their husband
and on social media like
they were talking [ __ ] about the woman
what like after she had died like
based on stuff she had posted on her
facebook and stuff oh my god i
can't i was in shock that's crazy crazy
so just when you think like there's
nothing negative someone could say about
something it's like no no they're there
and they'll say
of course no people are the [ __ ]
worst and like especially when it comes
to parenting like
every like i hate to use the word karen
because it's like so overused but that's
exactly what they are like why don't you
focus and fix your hair and
stop worrying about other people's lives
okay i just can't with everyone like
i've gotten so like triggered by people
like not even on my comment section like
on other people's comments like
over the weekend um i guess brittany
cartwright dressed up as the grinch and
she looks so cute she's like pregnant
and he had that like belly belly
and it was such a cute original costume
and i guess she i guess she got like so
much hate
for her body and like she's [ __ ]
pregnant
and body shaming yeah and like that she
didn't look right for 16 weeks
and she like had to put up this whole
thing on her instagram yesterday like i
got so mad on her behalf i like was
literally writing her message in all
caps i'm just like so
sensitive now it's like if somebody
literally comments like all right maybe
it's not the nicest but it's like
you didn't do this like it's not i'm so
i'm like what the [ __ ] did you just say
like
we all collectively we need to start
minding our own goddamn business like it
is so
imperative to our health our safety and
the safety of our country
that everybody just minds their own
goddamn business like it's so
important and honestly if you cannot
mind your own business which i
understand some people cannot like
you must throw your phone in a river and
just like move to an island because you
are un
you're undeserving of having a cell
phone and access to social media i think
that's so
on point it's at one point we have
reached peak
public shaming yep and we've got to come
back down
we just like in i can't say it in any
other words like we have got
to start mining our own business yeah
good got to
unless you have something nice to say
you know but you don't
but you don't you [ __ ] off yeah just
shut the [ __ ] up already my god
everyone's so tired of hearing you
well fifth and final story i think is
some news that will cheer you up because
taylor swift fans including party ashrae
are celebrating as the singer is now
free to re-record her original music no
it's like november 1st rolls around
everyone's like yes holiday season and
like november first rolls around for me
these are like re-recording season
beginning november 1st taylor swift can
now legally re-record new versions of
her first five albums which scooter
braun gained ownership of last year
following his 300 million dollar deal
with big machine label group after news
of the acquisition broke in june 2019
swift received support when she publicly
called him out and scott borchetta
however it was said that she was allowed
to record her music in november 2020
and her fans are celebrating accordingly
on social media and even got taylor is
free to begin trending on twitter
no it's so fabulous like one because i'm
happy for taylor and like her financials
like she'll be able to
record but for me it's like so many of
my favorite favorite favorite taylor
swift songs or like super early songs
before she was really big and like
they're kind of old now like 15 years
and it's like the production is like
maybe not as
you know keeping up with the times and
for me i'm just like really look and she
does so many different renditions like
some of my favorite songs like out of
the woods when it first came out i'm
like
oh my god lovey taylor but like this
song is like actually trash and then she
like re-um
structured it and she did this tour
version that like i ascend to heaven
when i hear it like it's so powerful and
first of all that's just the power of
taylor swift and second of all like
that version is so good and it's never
been properly recorded like i would love
to hear
that version i would love to hear like a
whole um version of her uh her holy
ground
uh not remix but she does like a new
version of it and it's just so different
and like there's her songs are just so
like simple that like they can be made
into anything yeah because they're all
just written on a guitar and then
they're made into like a pop song
they're made into a country song they're
made into a dance song
so like there's just so many
possibilities and like as a swifty i'm
just
i'm truly overjoyed it's a season of joy
so do you think she's going to re-record
all five or
choose like the greatest from the five
and put together like a reimagined
right early era album it seemed like it
would be easier for her to do like the
greatest hits because like
some of the songs like i mean they're
all amazing but some of them just aren't
as popular
i would love for her to do like album by
album re-record because then we get like
five new albums
but i do think it would make more sense
for her time even though we have so much
time these days like yeah but if she did
like a
20 song greatest hits like from her
first five albums like the most popular
the most iconic
like reimagined reimagined and then also
it's like so many of her songs that like
sh like her fans love so much like all
too well is like a fan favorite she
doesn't own that master and i feel like
since she's lost her masters she hasn't
been playing it that much because she
doesn't want to
give money to the people who she feels
stole from her so there's also so many
iconic songs that don't need to be
reimagined but
need to be recorded so she can start
playing them again and she can own them
yeah
i agree with that so just like like her
number ones like love story you know
right
no it's so sad like blank space like
those are the songs like made her career
now it's like blank space isn't one of
the first five is it
yeah shake it off yeah i mean what's it
199 no it went she only started
she only owns lover and um folklore no
but she her first one was taylor swift
then
uh fearless speak now red i guess it's
six albums sorry it's six
okay it's taylor swift debut it's all
your
other albums it's not like like just
some of them it's everything except for
lover and folk okay
because no reputation was not scott
barceta
it's not ready yet like it's just the
first five got it okay it's not ready
yet
is 1989 ts5 yes okay so that's it
1989 is truly like if you're ever
looking like oh you realize like you
hated taylor swift just because it's
like internalized misogyny and like you
just think like
you think it was cool because you were
like like a follower and now you're like
oh it's not cool to like to hey taylor
swift just not a personality trait and
like you're on this journey
i really implore you to take a dive into
1989. i think it's one of the best pop
albums of all time it's so brilliant
and the deluxe songs are like even
better it's just an
and then watch the concert dvd it's just
spectacular ooh that's a treat i watched
it actually last week
in celebration today i'll do a peloton
scenic ride with my um
taylor swift best of taylor playlist on
shuffles yeah it's a really it's on my
spotify the playlist it's just like some
of her
my all of her best songs like no skips
and
i'll just do a scenic ride to it and
then i let the song dictate my pace
it's so exciting like i said music's not
on peloton
really yeah oh also i never shared with
this group but i actually hit my 100th
peloton ride
which i know like you don't really care
about but i just think it's an
interesting factoid
i got my peloton two weeks into
quarantine so i've done 100
cycling rides i think i've done like 30
strength rides that's crazy yeah and i
get a free t-shirt so that's exciting
wow
that is exciting if you're a peloton
toaster use the hashtag pella toasters
so when we're all riding we can see each
other i heard we were trending
i heard we were trying to we're trending
the peloton community's
it's strong it's strong um but yeah so
it's just like an amazing time to be a
taylor swift fan and again i can't
recommend enough that like you drop the
internalized misogyny and just like
figure out
um like where to start where to start
yes there's
there's so much and now there's about to
be more yeah so it's like are we getting
one big album are we getting five new
ones i don't [ __ ] know
i'm a team i don't know this isn't a
prediction it's just like my personal
preference i'm team one big one me too i
just think it's like a lot of work for
her
um when at the end of the day there's
prop what do you think is the most
amount of songs you could put on an
album is there like a limit
no not with streaming right so i would
do like a 25 album
song 25 song album but she likes to put
out the albums so i'm sure
on a cd there might be a limit do you
think she's like already started yes
that's what i was gonna say like i guess
it would take time but i'm sure she's
been
like she has all of these she probably
has what do you want to sit in the booth
and just has all these other versions of
songs
yeah but and she has like all she
definitely has like a full-blown studio
where do you think she's quarantined
she's so many houses if you were her
where would you be
nashville she no she has a condo oh no
never mind i think which is a house too
but she also was like
a huge ass condo condo okay i think it
would be in rhode island
oh yeah she also has an amazing house in
la i would not be in new york even
though she has a sickening house in new
york and i feel like that's like her
maybe her favorite home do you think she
has a studio in her new york house
no because then she'd run into these
problems
she should get a little weighing away on
your new song but like if i could think
of like the perfect place to be
quarantined like
it would be rhode island yeah it's so
secluded she loves that house and it's
powerful yeah we went there just to see
what it was all about and
it was worth it we lived through 14 days
for three yeah
newport even though she's not in newport
she's in watch
something it's so so stunning i actually
wore this sweater there it has some new
it has some rhode island air on it
yeah like if i feel like if i needed to
write a powerful ballad like i would
just
drive up the coast sit at the beach and
it would just all come to me would you
ride up on the afternoon train yeah and
it's sunny and i would fly it all my
[ __ ] pack friends from the city that's
me [ __ ]
hey where are we going um all right so
those were the first five stories and i
definitely feel as though you needed to
know them you did it was a big weekend
like for celebs doing their celeb thangs
and now you know what they were up to
um let's talk about tv recap i really
need to talk about the queen's gambit
like i
it was only seven episodes and i feel
like i could have watched it in a day
but i was enjoying it so much like
i limited myself to like one or two
episodes over the course of a week me
too we kept on saying it was like a
treat just like sit down and treat
myself
and it really ended up being much more
different than i thought it would be
because
at first i was like loving beth and then
towards the end i'm like you [ __ ] like
yeah you idiot like
so gifted and like just kept making
[ __ ] bad choices like
uh and she really lost me as like a fan
when mr schaible died which was so sad
and we found out that she never paid him
back the ten dollars i i didn't even
pick up on that i don't know how i
missed it until you told me that she
never paid him back and i just assumed
that she did and like
i'm so upset by that and i'm also so
upset that like she never went back
while he was alive just to be like
thank you thank you for the ten dollars
thank you for teaching me chess and like
it was clear like when he you saw that
collage he was so proud of her and like
so invested in her career
honestly like i could cry like it was so
sad
like when she pulled up to that school
and there was that whole corkboard
and not even she'd have to go back and
visit him she never even [ __ ] called
him she wrote him once when she needed
the five dollars to enter the thing
she never paid him back and then she
never even turned back to say thank you
for the money thank you for teaching me
like it's so upsetting and i know it's a
fictional story because beth harmon was
not a real player i looked it up yeah
but like
i'm still mad because mr scheible
deserved more yeah and he was a beth
harman stan
and and even if she didn't want to say
thank you or pay him back like
he deserved to see her like thriving
it's so upsetting and like and she
weaseled her and i think that
giving him a mention in the press
posthumously
is gonna help he's gonna make up for all
the [ __ ] no and
i was really like like down on beth but
then when jolene showed up and like
saved her i was so grateful because i
missed jolene from the orphanage
and she had her life together unlike
beth and she loaned her the money even
though she'd been saving up for law
school which really upset me really
upset me like for years beth was just
like
making money spending it on all of these
clothes redesigning the house buying a
house
some of them the clothes yes they were
investments like that white coat at the
end sickening the house down i can't and
i shan't but like
she was literally just like farting
money for so many years and then the
only way and she literally
denied the christian right that's the
thing just because she couldn't declare
her but she's fine to take it from a
friend who's been working so hard to
save up for something that's so
important to her yeah and we know that
since she won
in moscow that she will be paying yeah
of course hopefully well she didn't pay
mr scheibel back ten dollars how do we
know she's gonna pay jolene back
three thousand dollars right but it just
was like really upsetting that that's
how she had to get the money yeah i
wanted the story
like to be real so badly because now
it's just like okay what was the point
but um i just loved learning about the
world of chess
yeah it was really interesting we
actually know how to play chess so like
i felt like i had a leg up on watching
it because i understood what they were
saying but
to me it's like you're just like when we
used to play it was just like you're
moving pieces
waiting for it to be over no and i think
that like when you become like a grand
master it's like when you were a kid
like you
you totally like get like the whole like
we used to play as kids we used to take
lessons as kids and like i never really
like
cared or like got the point yeah and i
never saw like we were just like sure
you're not smart enough right and so
like i feel like when she learned and
she like literally learned how to play
just like by watching and then like
looking up and taking drugs and like oh
my god
the scene where she crap broke into the
infirmary in the school and was like
shoving those green pills
that was insane insane they were
drugging the campers at first when i
turned it on i was like
what the [ __ ] what is going on like
they're driving campers this is too much
for me and i didn't really know what the
show was going to be
about and it was going to be like you
know the whole trajectory
of her i guess it started in paris which
another
major disappointment where she
completely botches
the match against borogov when she's in
paris because like she goes
hungry for a drink hungover and that
girl totally sabotaged her
cleo that was just really disappointing
yeah and the other thing that really
bothered me is that like she was kind of
like just a shitty friend to everyone
and all these people like henry and
billy they all looked out for her like
the chess community in
kentucky like they just towns they just
cared about her even though she was like
the worst [ __ ] friend
never answered the phone or opened the
door and then like the morning of her
competition like she wakes up and
they're all together on the phone giving
her all the plays and
and it's like you didn't deserve that
type of friendship from those people
because you were a horrible friend to
them
yes but in her defense like the trauma
that she had gone through in her life
yes
you know isn't conducive for her to
being a team player
yes um and so when they did all show up
for her and all of those guys got
together like i think she realized in
this moment oh
i do have a family yeah no i know oh
speaking of family also
her mom her the one her doctor her
adopted mom
was just a hero like a hero i was
worried at first and i said on the show
i was like hopefully she doesn't steal
from her but eventually like
because she was so weird at first like
with the piano and we're like is she
a good person like she's looking out for
bethesda and she
took her to the store to shop and just
like wouldn't let her buy the chest
thing
yeah it was bizarre but then she turned
into a true supporter a great team
and it was nice that beth had someone in
her corner yeah and
then when she passed away it was just
devastating it was really sad
it was a really good show if you guys
haven't watched it definitely watch it
it's
there's nothing not to like and the
fashion oh my god
sickening so so good it gets better
every episode like as
beth becomes more herself and like earns
more money and like her
the last scene her outfit like my i
my jaw hit the floor oh and then there
was this just wonderful message at the
end
that it was like we're all just people
we all just love chess and yes you live
in russia but like we're all
because this was like at a the 60s it
was like heightened
political times between russia and
america and she had to go with the
security guard and she couldn't go
anywhere without the security guard and
then she just walked through the park
and all these guys just loved chess and
they loved her and it was like
we're all just people yeah it was
beautiful it was a great
message of unity during these divisive
times yes it was really really good
really well done
show that actress is spectacular i don't
know do you ever see the movie
thoroughbreds
no she's in it i looked her up after
because i was like who is this fabulous
girl
well billy the friend is from game of
thrones
and he's the voice of phineas and ferb
ferb
and he is the little kid from love
actually the one who was like the cutest
kid remember how last week i made an
announcement on the show that i'm the
girl who's never seen the big lebowski
yeah i am also the girl who's never seen
love actually which is crazy yeah and i
actually think he would like it
no i know but at this point i just like
that it's like a thing about me that
i've never seen and i'm like i'm so
invested in pop culture like i know
everything about it but like i'm just
too good for love actually you know yeah
and i feel like for you it makes you
feel
young because it's kind of like an old
movie you are just so smart
yeah you're like i'm too young to have
seen that you know i was just like a
baby
um so yes queen's gabbit i would give a
five out of five like just highly
recommend
during these unprecedented times you
need something that's gonna take you to
another world
well done it's all of those things yeah
um
and then real housewives of potomac was
on last night and i just
you know really i boarded the ship last
week and now we have set sail because
i'm so in love with karen huger
and after the whole wendy's slithering
thing like
she has just got me as a lifelong fan
and when wendy sat her down and was like
ready to tear her new one about how she
came for her education i was like
oh this is a tough corner like that
karen's backed into and then karen just
popped off i literally was in my bed
like yeah go
karen well there were two things going
on this episode one it's that giselle is
the shadiest [ __ ] alive like
i'm double i'm done because you want to
know why she was being shady when
she told wendy that karen called her a
floozy freelancer which she didn't all
she said was that she was a freelance
correspondent for cnn that's all she
said
so she was stirring the pop there then
she was stirring the pot going to karen
saying wendy said
that you wanted your money back from rey
when they replayed that clip
she was drunk and she was making a joke
about wanting the money
that was not serious and then when they
had karen come to tea and
giselle was like you know i heard this
from wendy and i want to be there for
karen it's clearly weighing on her like
i want to be a friend to her so they sit
down and have that conversation and
karen
then says about the conversation with
wendy and gisele immediately goes to
wendy and like reenacts everything that
karen said and it's like what happened
to wanting to be a friend to her
part of being a friend is just like like
absorbing information and conversations
and not
running and telling everyone and then
also with her like mean joke to robin
about her hat company being called
embezzled when like she's going through
this financial crisis like that was so
obviously just shady
and i live for the shadiness but you
can't play every [ __ ] side like you
have to choose
a few yeah not one but like she was just
being so
obviously like a potster and she's
really making like a fight between two
powerful women
and where where they had some tension in
the beginning but it could have been
resolved now it's like so much worse
literally because of giselle for sure
and at the end of the episode when karen
was like
yeah i have this thing with wendy
whatever but i'm looking at you giselle
like
i like i know that it's the way that you
said it to her i was like thank you like
and this isn't sure her thank you for
looking beyond yeah her and wendy need
to like just figure this small thing out
but the bigger issue is that
no one can trust gisele not only will
she tell everyone everything you say
about anyone else she will do it with a
spin that makes it even more negative
and just causing strife in the group and
and i i just i'm not interested in that
like
yeah i agree it's just petty and it it's
not real drama and
yeah part of being a great cast member
is like being a good friend and like
just being a trustworthy person and also
being on a a side whether it's the right
side or the wrong side but just to like
be in the middle and just make everyone
around you
like feel like they are always going to
have to defend themselves like why would
anyone want to go to lunch with you but
like dead ass like karen imitating and
then all the women getting in the train
hilarious no but karen turned that
situation that is why she is
a queen an icon like she literally got
back into a corner
and managed to turn the entire situation
where everybody is doing like
the sleuthing the sleuth out the door
but okay i have a really big problem
with wendy because
i feel really conflicted because when
we're in her home scenes and like she's
talking to her kids and
her kids are like integrity is doing the
right thing when no one's looking i'm
like oh my god she's literally the most
amazing mom i'm like these kids are in
such good hands and then in her
professional life i'm like oh my god
this woman's so accomplished
four degrees and cnn and msnbc
and you're like yes doctor this is what
we need and then when she gets with the
women she's so irrational
and she's always wrong like i'm always
disagreeing with always wrong and
sorry it's an amazing thing to have four
degrees and it's
such an accomplishment but it can't be
your answer for everything
agreed and i wouldn't have thought that
but they showed that flashback where in
every fight that she's been in she
throws out four degrees
dr wendy address me properly you don't
get four degrees so you can come on real
housewives and let everyone know you had
four degrees at every turn it's also
it's
it's literally never part of the
conversation in this particular fight it
was
yeah because karen was like saying
you're not a medical doctor but in most
of the fights like
literally it's like nobody wendy i have
four degrees like we get it it's just
not applicable here but it is applicable
in other situations
just not here and it's starting to annoy
me and
i like her in every scene when she's not
with the other one yeah i don't like her
in the group context also because like
she will always have candace's
back that came in as friends it's a
crutch and so
uh and i'm just like completely out on
candace what was crazy though is seeing
the scene where monique like
files charges against candice and canis
is so delusional
you just sue someone and nothing happens
and you just win because you think
you're right
right and like candace when she was in
her house talking to chris and she was
so
bothered by what monique had done but
also saying that it was like a bad legal
move but like
it clearly got under your skin the thing
is is that and what candace knows is
first of all
whoever you think is right or wrong now
in the legal sense everyone does what
they have to do to protect themselves
whether nobody wants to go to jail
nobody wants to get arrested nobody
wants to have this like on their file
forever
so now it's like every person is
lawyered up and when it comes to lawyers
and like means to pay lawyers monique
has way more means to do that
she could fight this longer than candace
because we know that candace has
financial instability because her mom is
super rich but she doesn't always get
money from her mom she doesn't want to
take money from a mom we've been talking
about it for five years we know
so it's like now it's like in a battle
of lawyers and money
monique wins yeah and to just assume
that you're gonna sue someone
and nothing's gonna happen they're not
gonna fight back and
you're just gonna win because you think
you're right like because you have
post-it notes all over your house
what an irrational thing to think and to
get so mad at someone else
for counter-suing is a level of delusion
that i can't relate to like
once you take it to like the legal she
took it there first 100
candice filed the charges she was the
one who made it a legal matter
now you're mad that someone else is
protecting themselves and their family
like that makes no [ __ ] sense
no no sentence she's being so irrational
yeah and
i'm i'm happy that monique is standing
up for herself especially
in light of the fact when you slow down
the footage uh candace put her hands on
monique's
body monique then posted a screenshot of
an email from the whole thing where they
decided to drop the charges because the
like the maryland district attorney was
like
um we've reviewed all the
the paperwork the counter sue the sue
the bravo
footage bravo literature footage and
we've decided we're dropping the charges
so it's like
the law actually decided that both of
you are wrong
right so so the group should follow suit
should follow
suit yes i agree i mean so also monique
is not going on the trip
yeah i thought she might be because it
was ashley strauss you know what i'm
glad because if monique went on the trip
everything would be about monique
monique would be the villain
and it would but now that the women will
be together and you're gonna take out
monique who you think is the problem
toxic
let's find out who the problem really is
that always happens also one more thing
gisele did really bothered me when
ashley came over to her house and she
was like being such like a baby about
breastfeeding it's like
you're three kids and ashley it's like
who look people who are like boobies
like
who cares and your mom you've literally
had three kids like let her breastfeed
and like
make her feel weird about it yeah oh
you're gonna you're gonna rip it out
right now like who [ __ ] cares
yeah that was bothering me i'm just i'm
just like a little turned on yourself no
i'm
i'm extremely and like i always like
even though i've never agreed with her
in like group situations i just love her
so i was like i don't really care but i
i now care because now she's coming for
karen
yeah she's coming for karen she's come
for monique and
i i'm with karen and monique and i know
they're not a team technically but like
karen monique and ashley like are my
rider dies
currently 100 i actually think that we
are
in the popular opinion i hope so i do so
tough
i actually don't know actually like when
i look at twitter that's what i didn't
look last night but that i
i tend to agree but i don't know i feel
like sometimes
podcast listeners don't agree yeah um
but it was actually a pretty good
episode and of course next week looks
great which is
what we say here every week about the
real houses of potomac but this was
pretty good yeah
pretty good so the other thing that i
watch american murder do you think
you're gonna watch it no
it's it's a documentary that's an hour
and a half which i loved
oh just one episode one episode after
having watched wild wild country like
i just i'm so here for it what is so
crazy is
they usually documentary they have
interviews with people you know they do
this whole thing
they used all footage from um shannon's
social media like because she
posted so many videos of her life and
her daughter's like we have literally a
whole documentary of like home videos
from her facebook
um police footage and like news
real footage like they didn't have to do
any in sit-down interviews nothing it's
all
like there so ring doorbell
you get the whole picture neighbors
camera footage like
that's crazy and like everyone in their
own words at the time not people
like uh recalling it so the husband
killed
his wife and two kids yeah and why did
he do it um
so i mean there's never a reason why
would but i thought this when i first
heard this i'm like why
like what is his happen recently 2018.
was it the woman who was pregnant yes oh
my god i remember that story
um it is so crazy maybe i will watch it
actually
i was very struck by that story it's
extremely well done there was
like one part where he like explains
he's like confessing to his dad what he
did and like where they are
and how do they have that tape the
police he was in the police room
oh um like the he took a lie detector
test and then he asked
like it's all just being recorded and
when he says where the girls are okay
wait you know what i'm definitely gonna
watch this now i just
i'm definitely gonna watch it okay
what's called american murder the family
next
i didn't know i remember that story it
was like the biggest news story and it
was so
shocking yeah it's just a really well
done documentary it's a horrible
horrible story i definitely am going to
watch it
yeah okay thanks um and i think that's
all
she wrote that's all she wrote yeah yeah
all she had written make sure to
pre-order my book girlsnowjob.combook
and have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for tuesday it's
also election day so don't forget to
vote don't forget to vote make a plan to
vote make a plan go with a friend
wear a mask wear a mask and do what you
got to do
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast milani morning show
where we deliver the five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday
on youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes central public radio i
have radio stocks all the places
wherever you listen to podcast find out
some morning toast and leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow goodbye